[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we are discussing embracing
and maturity and we wanted to bring on
some people to talk with us who can hang
out with us on an air biscuit discussing
immature embracing and maturity most
immature in the office so we've got Mike
and Alex is that a compliment well
should you know honored man that is the
thesis by that by the end of this
conversation I think we will thoroughly
unpack the fact that absolutely it's a
compliment
welcome to the fold boys we're never
gonna grow up excited to be here really
in the realm of never going sorry we
made you wait no sorry link made you
wait no that's good we're here now I had
to eat a salad then I had to get salad
out my teeth I had to sit there and
listen to him eat a salad which is
always experience okay so we are gonna
talk about embracing a maturity which is
a chapter in the book of mythicality
we'll talk all about that we're gonna
talk about your guys show 10 feet tall
I'm wearing the t-shirt I see it looks
great at night on the you've got a you
have a derivative ten feet tall you know
but too because your guys show kind of
embodies that but before we do that you
just passed another threshold I did yeah
as in you had a birthday I did how did
you turn we were gonna celebrate your
birthday oh yeah and then on the side
right you weren't there for it I mean it
was and miss my own birthday celebration
here here because you you left sick yeah
did you was i planning on I think all
did you turn I didn't mean what was the
rats question oh man this is kind of
hard to say but 28 for me that's scary
that's spooky
okay yikes it's uh it's a good number
turn 28 Mike how old are you 24
soo-jung y'see yeah you 225 one month
we're all crossing that threshold to
here yeah everybody has birthdays I
genuinely forgot though what cuz you you
told people to get you cheesecake and
then you just left and didn't tell me
you were sick I was sick yeah I mean I
still ate the Cheesecake it didn't
matter that you weren't here I was happy
for everyone who enjoyed my gee what
happened
I'm mister I mean I came into work that
morning and then it was like well I
don't know you were there it was like
9:30 and I was looking at my can I go
there's no way like we were supposed to
shoot that day and I was just like I
feel like I could throw up at any second
and then I Rotten I looked screams my
best I could describe you look like a
sewer boy a sewer boy I felt kind of
like a sewer boy I just felt more of
like I was coming to look that up on
urban dictionary and also freezing at
the same time and I was just like I lay
down on our couch up and our little loft
and I was just like Mike there's no way
I can shoot today and then I was just
like I had a flight out at 4:00 a.m.
that next morning Oh that night that
night yeah exactly
well my flight was like 6:00 but I had
to get in an uber by 4:00 I'm sorry I
have to go
so I went Kody's office and I was just
like there's nothing good as happening
you vomited in there
no I vomited when I got home and then I
would yeah oh yeah but okay but didn't
you was it the day before that you shot
that censored food thing yes oh yeah I
didn't really put that together sort of
well Stevie was the one who said that
because she was because the interesting
thing was and that videos is is out on
this is mythical but so you did the
censored food video where everything
that you're eating and is you're making
is censored visually but everything that
you're talking about is also censored
yeah yeah but she came to she was
explaining to me she was like Alex is
sick and I think it's probably because
of that I think she might be on to
something
and the funny thing is is they made
gross stuff and they put like dirty mop
water in one of the dishes and they
didn't need to because the whole thing
was censored yeah funny how that works
out but get her me
yeah what wasn't as authentic I mean I
appreciated leaving our recipe out of
that it was sense it for a reason mop
okay now you guys have one of these
that's on me that I read to you yeah
that's right I knew we'd see color I'm
suppose they could have changed that in
post but I said we need something black
that's right we always get something
black in the next usually but you don't
think it was food poisoning no I felt
horrible I mean I was in New York that
weekend with my girlfriend and it was
just like awful like that whole week I
was like that's where you were flying
yeah yeah yeah on a being on a plane
sick is not good no a well I remember
this is this is awful because I
essentially just was like sick that
whole time and then I got on a plane and
we were about to take off and I was like
wow I'm gonna throw up right now and
then I was like there's a bag for that
well it wasn't in front of me though so
I was like how could I get to the
bathroom while the plane is taking off I
was like thinking like you can't is that
physically possible no I probably could
do it but you would be tackled are you
telling me what did you look for the
barf bag because no they're not in the
thing any they're real good in the 90s a
barf bag in every not in the seats
anymore you got to get them from the
bathroom on one Delta oh we're gonna
save money on barf bags but we're gonna
lose a lot of money on having to clean
up barf what did you do looked i toughed
it out you got to go deep into the pouch
though really so it's not in the power
down to like finding a baby kangaroo
yeah yeah what opening sticking way down
in there or just barfing into the actual
but then we're taking off and then it's
coming back at me you know no into the
magazine holder oh yeah I don't know I
just like was in a catatonic weird stay
you saved it off yeah it was like a
mental battle
deep breathing focusing yeah breathe out
in through your nose and out through
your mouth it was an experience I've
never had a flight like that the guy
next to me probably thought I was on
drugs never give you were you were
contagious man yeah on a plane but in
love you know had to get had to get up
get out there get sick later eventually
I think she's alright
she'll be all right doctor
she already knew to keep her did you so
did you vomit anywhere
I only the only time I threw it was when
I went home after work not in the plane
not on the plane you got better at while
you're anew yeah hmm well happy birthday
yeah cheesecake was great yeah well I
missed it but it sounded great now you
guys are roommates in real life that's
not just for the show boys live together
make it happen
wait let me make week man done day so I
when he leaves what what do you do get
separation anxiety no I mean I tend to
leave - I guess that makes it sound like
I can't be alone no we do that because
it's like for scheduling obviously if so
you went back home I did oh you did
I did go your lives are getting in sync
you have to take Simon's menstrual
cycles everything happens your cycles
come in
I've been synched up with you for you
okay we're gonna talk about your show
but I thought a good way to get into
this whole embracing immaturity was to
bring up this article and it is a whole
yeah it is the big it's just like the
pouch in the back of a Airlines okay
back in July of this year we were
featured we were mentioned in a New York
Times article do you know about this no
by Jennifer was that Weiner or wider
this is the best part about me about the
article good night I don't want about I
mean I'm already being immature about it
but I honestly don't know because you
consider printer name is you can say
Weiner Weiner not sure
she absolutely hates oh yeah this
conversations as well a couple wieners
in its Wiener yeah Jennifer Weiner wrote
an article and op-ed in The New York
Times called the men who never have to
grow up and the big picture that is
featured here is Donald Trump jr.
laughing in a field in a flannel shirt
and baggy jeans and the the premise of
this article is basically that there is
the sentiment that runs deep in American
culture that says boys will be boys and
therefore men can get away with anything
you know like we've got men who are in
their 30s who mid to late 30s who should
be grown-ups but act like kids and we
excuse their bad behavior so she talks
about Teddy Kennedy and the whole bridge
situation with the girl that drowned and
like tactful you know the way the way
that he when he's 37 years old at the
time and like he was kind of excused for
that because boys will be boys and then
they talk about then all of a sudden
they started talking that wasn't that's
not current it knows I'm gonna be
talking about like a current trend that
Donald Trump jr. is Yoshi poster boy he
goes on to say this is when we get
mentioned okay this is and then she gets
back into Trump here in a second but we
can laugh but we should also recognize
that Americans have a soft spot for our
troublemakers and scamp's stamp I didn't
know that word who are as wailing Waylon
Jennings sang of Bo and Luke Duke good
ol boys never meanin no harm start with
YouTube which is crammed with fellows in
their 30s and 40s mmm who have declined
to put away childish things and have
instead made their fortunes by singing
love songs to their pillows or
performing trick basketball shots and
then the love songs to the pillows
there's a link is that us oh yeah it is
that is us oh good they link to the
video more views six millions of
subscribers watch rhett mclaughlin and
link Neal that's us both 3900 39 not for
long baby eat bugs or play will it taco
with pine needles and then they talk
about this other dude
and then the and then Colin Furze the 37
year old inventor with his 360 degree
swing and his wearable Wolverine claws
is also huge moving on to Ryan Seacrest
and then Chris Hardwick and then Billy
Bush whoa okay we just escalate yeah now
we're in Billy Bush territory and then
she comes out of the bush and then she
brings up Donald Trump jr. again which
and okay and Ryan latke yeah right so
and the idea and she brings up the whole
the Russia scandal and his in this point
everyone was talking about his meeting
that he had and so her point is is that
there this is pervasive and culture but
then she brings ups camps and
troublemakers and throws us and by the
way Ryan Seacrest Ryan doesn't face no
scam so I mean I do think we fit no no
you can say yeah no but well I think
first of all there's lots of comments on
this article and thank you to all the
mythical beasts who came in to comment
and came to our defense and kind of
pointed out somehow I be the first of
all credit to miss Weiner because she
she did it she did the thing that you
need to do when you write an article and
that is you got a you got to get people
talking about it and I tweeted about
this I said I'm not sure why we were
included and then Chris Hardwick
responded to that tweet and he's
obviously he's more popular than we are
he's tweeting about it so
congratulations Jennifer because people
talked about your article mission
accomplished but I thanks to you I think
one of the things we're gonna talk about
is the difference between being a
troublemaker or a scamp and being
somebody who's young at heart and likes
to have a good time and I think she
conflated those things well can we just
get out of the way the fact that we are
we are professional comedians whether
you're a male a female no matter who you
are if your job is to be an entertainer
and a comedian I it's there's a long
long history of nahma irrespective of
your age embracing image
as part of the job a part of the job
right I mean I'm not a freaking
politician or the son of one yeah and
we're not getting away with things or
morally questionable things because
we're having a good time back in like
fools and and we're but the accusation
is that we are contributing to a culture
culture where oh you you know boys will
be boys just it's just harmless little
scamp egde just just let them off the
hook kind of thing because this is the
example of that we provide there's a
disconnect there but I don't know what
it is well I just I don't get it well I
don't get the connection well I can't
remember what Hardwick tweeted but he
basically said something like I am a
responsible adult who you know owns a
company and or whatever we can say the
same thing
married with children fathers of
teenagers but at this point running a
media company in Los Angeles so there's
a mature part like we've taken
responsibility for quality
responsibility for our own actions and
our own you know I would even say
influenced yeah
but but that is unrelated to acting like
a fool for the sake of entertainment I
think and you guys act like fools
non-stop I mean we say one of the
tenants of mythicality in the book is
tom foolery bringing that back yeah as a
term curiosity creativity and tom
foolery I mean you're building a whole
show around it yeah right yeah
absolutely you feel guilty now not well
you guys ii guess ii know i did i think
it's weird to I just think it's a weird
thing to call people out for also it's
just like I feel like people want to
discredit things so they see like oh
this is like a fun goofy thing and they
want to discredit it as like oh it's
silly and dumb when in reality I as
people who work behind the scenes on a
bunch of shows here it's like there's so
much creativity and things that go into
the all the work here and
I don't know people just want to
discredit that without giving it any
credence for a reason I don't understand
well it's it's one this is we say this
all the time it's like we try to be very
smart about being stupid right we try to
do different things in a smart way so
it's in you and that's what you guys do
is it so you have your the reasons that
you come up with on the show to do the
things that you're going to do for the
sake of entertainment make it seem like
you're just a couple of guys who kind of
sit in a loft all day yeah wait until
something inspires you but you guys also
produce the show yeah right yeah we do
everything with the show I mean it's a
lot I wish that we could just sit down
laughing there's an element of that yeah
but we're not that person 24 hours a day
seven days a week right yeah we're that
never get the show wouldn't get done
we'd never be able to do anything we
just be doing really stupid stuff so I'd
say naturally sure where we're imbeciles
for maybe a see fifty-fifty part of the
day sure by then but it's like we do sit
around we talk about why why do we want
to do this idea okay that's a good
question what goes through your minds
when you come up with the things that
you guys want to do on the show I think
the main thing the first thing that
drives us is has anybody done anything
like this before and I think that drives
all the shows here for the most part
yeah especially GMM I mean it's like the
main thing I mean we're always
cross-checking everything to be like has
anyone done anything even like this
before and so I think we have a little
bit more like pull to kind of do way off
out the wall out the wall stuff not even
off the wall Wow most people have said
off the wall yeah you made a choice
right there yeah exactly I must say I'm
saying off the wall it's out the wall
right pretend Pete's all right what
rhymes out the wall with ten feet tall
yeah exactly but we're always trying to
do just different we want to be
different we can be anybody can be weird
and stupid
but you got to do it in a different more
creative way which is what we try to do
what is it this does something you've
shot stand out like Tim as a moment of
just another day I always say when there
midlist when we're in the middle of
something really stupid that we're doing
that I mean again we're talking about we
fully calculated why we're doing it and
how it's gonna be fun for the audience
but then what I'm doing it's just like
man
no this isn't this is another day at the
office
doing something totally stupid yeah and
I mean you can see these things and then
when you're in it or dangling from it or
trying to sell it or whatever it is I
mean you to me that if you're having
those moments and we're doing you're
doing something right yeah I think
moments like what are the best moments
the know far the moments of like pure
creativity that you can like see us
figuring out as you go the ones that I
like the best like we did this thing
with two giant teddy bears where
essentially there was no game plan like
how we're gonna make that work like we
were just like we want to do a battle
with two giant teddy bears and so you
can see us figuring it out on camera I'm
like discovering what everything was
gonna be because we had no idea if
anything that would work at all or even
if we could get inside and that's when
you can tell we're having I think that's
what people love is when they can see
we're actually having a ton of fun doing
something exploring something we didn't
know would work or not yeah anyone who
does work it's incredibly insane right
like that there's this curiosity like
well how do I can we get a bear big
enough how do I get in it right how do I
get out of it how do I always fight in
it how of course documenting that is
super important to us
yeah like capturing those moments where
it's like usually everyone discovers
America can do it yeah no it's weird too
because I think that's kind of what
we're talking about earlier it's like
going back to those childhood moments
where you're with your friend maybe and
you have two giant teddy bears like your
sisters or something like we're not
doing anything today
we should do something weird with these
teddy bears and like that's what we want
the show to be like it's like you're
there with your best friend just like
trying to figure out something to do and
then you make something totally crazy
happen yeah and I think the interesting
thing is that you know your show I mean
we in the same way that GMM has a broad
audience in terms of age you know the
kind of the peak demographic of people
who watch GMM is 18 to 24 mm-hm the
second highest group is 25 to 34 and
then it's actually 13 to 17 the youngest
kids are that's their third so the
interesting thing is what we're doing
really dumb stuff you guys are doing
really dumb stuff as well but let's say
silly I don't even want to say like oh
it's a mythical we can use the term
mythical because it's hitting the
trifecta you know creativity curiosity
yeah foolery it's not just it's not dumb
it's not stupid it's not Jack well it's
Tom the point is to finish the point
adults are watching this and I think
because it appeals to people right right
seeing grown people do silly stuff it
appeals to people because it's not when
we kind of lock ourselves into this is
where I kind of take issue with miss
weiners article or at least being
included in it I don't think I'm not
saying that her her the thing about the
culture and the gate when you boys will
be boys is wrong I'm saying that
including us as an example of that where
I disagree with that is the fact that
people get locked into quote-unquote
normal jobs you grow up and you've got
real responsibilities and it can be come
very easy to just be consuming those
responsibilities and never have any
outlet for your fun right if you've got
a job we're in first of all lots of
people have jobs where they've got to be
serious the entire day and those people
are you know I don't want my doctor in a
teddy bear suit you know what I'm saying
so but that doesn't mean that he's not
gonna have he or she is not gonna have
an outlet for tomfoolery in their life
and I think that it's your show is an
escape for that from that and it's not
the links point it's not just one thing
is not
just tomfoolery right if it was just
stupid and that was all that was which
there are a lot of YouTube videos that
are just stupid but if it if it but it
has an originality creativity and a
curiosity factor to it that I think kind
of redeems and letting letting makes you
feel as a responsible adult I can get
into this I can laugh at it and not feel
like I'm just wasting my time right well
you know I I think when we talked about
like starting Tim feet all and what it
was gonna look like and in addition to
also saying okay this is a starting
point these are some ideas let's agree
on what this is and then you guys go and
make it happen and then make it your own
and it'll morph over time even with that
being said as a side note I remember
talking early on about some of the first
ideas and we talked about jackass about
how well we're not gonna we're not just
gonna make another version of jackass
if you guys want to do weird things it's
like these are some other elements that
I think you guys were interested
including that we've already talked
about but then I actually don't even
want to throw jackass under the bus I
didn't I didn't watch it a whole lot and
I haven't watched any of the movies
we've actually we talked about the
movies cuz you've watched them yeah and
you're like you actually need to watch
them because there's a level of
creativity that went into a lot of the
way that they that they did those stunts
I my second so even something like
Jackass you may say well that is just
plain stupid I mean just does getting
hit in the balls I mean that gets old
there's a level of creativity that went
into what what they did it again we want
to do we want to do something different
I think mythicality includes some other
things besides that but I can't even
write that off and say I can't even
point to jackass and say well that's
what that's kind of base level right and
we're gonna keep talking about that but
first we're gonna take a short break to
show some love to our sponsors well
first of all
we're wearing with we're wearing the
merch that we want to talk about I mean
we got 10 feet tall t-shirts I got on a
10 feet tall
pocket tee you got all the goth dogs
t-shirt from your goth dogs video when I
that was like one of the early episodes
one of my favorites to this day
Mike's got on a striped prison tee not
selling that yeah is the couch but you
can get those kind of shot shirt can't
get that t-shirt but you can get the two
great t-shirts in mythical dots store
you can also pre-order the book of
mythicality at book of mythicality calm
and you know again this whole
conversation is is related to and
inspired by the chapter embracing
maturity where link and I talk about the
sort of the the spirit of never
completely growing up never letting
yourself fully grow up and we talked
about how we kind of connected and then
how we've used good mythical morning to
explore that and some of the peaks of
immaturity that we've experienced
together booked them at the county calm
but let's continue this conversation
well I mean the fact that we wrote about
we dedicated a whole chapter to
embracing and maturity in the book of
mythicality I think the reason why we
did that is because we wanted to tap
back into the experiences we have when
we you know when we were just becoming
friends and I guess over the well over
the years and even with GMM the way that
we stay in touch with our inner child
you know and I think that's what you
guys bring to ten feet tall and what we
bring to GMM is the we kind of we
channel viewers into their inner child
you know it's like okay I remember I
used to feel that way I wish I could
jump headlong into a bowl of cereal
right or dangled from a crane you know
it's a lot more painful when did you
guys realize that you both were like you
obviously had to connect as friends but
then realize that you're both willing to
act like fools okay yeah because the it
isn't you know it isn't for everybody
right you know acting that actually that
way appreciating adults isn't for
everybody so you have to find somebody
who's willing to think that way like
what was the initial because you were
already here Alex you were working here
yeah everything I remember it and you
started as a PA right as an intern as an
intern
yes it was probably oh I know remember
yeah sure yeah the does it have anything
to do with a cigarette oh okay I think
that's where it really hit its peak oh
he's got earlier where we really know we
had something there we'll come back to
that way you're going earlier well I was
probably like three weeks into my
internship oh you know I'm fresh out of
college I'm really nervous like first
job in the industry yeah we thought Mike
was a mute I was like we gotta we gotta
make good impression you know all your
professors are like if you screw up the
first one Oh later oh you were thinking
that like it's hard enough to even get
like an interview of you trying to not
screw it up with no but I remember there
was an insert you interviewed him
remember we were loading a van for
something and we were carrying a table
and you asked me if it was too heavy or
something I don't remember exactly what
I said I know it was very inappropriate
and I don't remember why I said it but
you laughed so hard no so sure I was
like fine like meeting someone for the
first time after he said something yeah
and be it was funny yeah very funny
Bobby there were there are questions
about Mike right sure but people be like
he doesn't talk a lot it I remember link
asking what time is he upset about
something was is he upset about
everything and then Stevie was like no
no no Mike is actually really funny ask
Alex
the application wasn't Mike is really
funny just hang out when the robot was
just notice go straight to Alice was the
ecig thing we liked Eddie was going
through a period where he was vaping a
lot and Mike microtome you could vape
anything so it is such a stupid thing
like pick up a glass and you'd be like
like pretend vaping a glass and then I
was like Mike please don't bathe the
building like it's the dumbest thing we
went to had he had like a housewarming
party or something oh yeah I went there
and there was a guy there who's super
like hardcore into vaping okay really
not the culture about a talking about
his box mods on but I went there and I
did the vape that meaning you you he
pretended to vape like a pencil scooter
I think there's a razor scooter in the
room so you made fun of the guy to his
face yeah and I thought guy didn't like
it I he didn't get it happens a lot
no I remember I remember I was like the
best oh those are my favorite I'm only
your friend get yeah I'm a selfish
making you go up and talk to him though
be like hey go tell that guy that you
could make anything like oh my was a
sponsored let you are the route you were
with razor was so wild I wonder if he
bought a scooter after that he was
interested vape culture is very very
very defensive like when we did that
whole we brought the Surgeon General I'm
talk about e-cigarettes yeah oh man we
had some people who were just like
boycotted the show because we said we
let the Surgeon General come on and say
scientific things about vaping there's I
remember a guy made a response video and
he did like like a beat for beat like
every ten seconds he would interrupt
them here's the problem today you're
wrong man and he's like ripping his
little babe oh I'm sorry for all the
vapors and you know what is that why the
Surgeon General got fired yeah
response video it really said we did it
thank you to all the vapors you're still
with us you know yes I keep vaping but
general was fired so I mean but this
design it still backs him up yeah one of
things I want to talk about too was the
I think we've got speaking of science I
think we've got science on our side you
know we do it we do it we do a job where
we get to do a lot of foolish things
right and I think that that has kind of
caused us to perceive ourselves as
younger than we actually are
we were talking about earlier today that
like when I watch I mean I'm gonna be 40
in October but when I watch like the NBA
they all seem older than me James Harden
at least 45 like they're always like
when do you start like now they're also
more talented and yet Vince Carter
Vince Carter is older than me but he may
be like the only one right now at what
point do you begin to feel older than
NBA basketball players or just
professional athletes in general I think
the question is does the average 39 year
old feel that way when they watch NBA
yeah I feel like they're older than me
and I've seen him in person
there are also athletes and you've been
watching that since you were a kid right
there's other things but then like you
you know like sometimes you'll you'll
just well I will meet somebody you'll
meet somebody well and then you'll find
out that dudes 39 that dude's younger
than me I will meet people it happens a
lot and I'm talking about looking old
I'm not talking about like looking old
no it's always a total package yeah yeah
acting old like I will meet parents of
my of
friends of my kids that's one way to put
it and what parents of my kids friends
parents that's another way to and I just
find myself thinking like I literally
think that I would like I'm wearing it I
had a kid like they're taking out juice
boxes and they give you would you like
would you like a sliced orange I'm here
I'm here to support the kids in their
sports or whatever cuz I'm like wearing
a hat or like a I'm wearing a freaking
t-shirt with a dog on it right and then
I'm wearing like a trendy hat and at
some point mean not that trendy Mike
that's weird to me that's how I know
when I wear hat know when you be on sure
sure when I walk through the office it
is a little weird I've never asked my
dad but I always wonder did he dress
like this forever
yeah or did it happen at some point it
happened that's the question when when
wanna make the transition well he got a
real job we never got real jobs remains
motto we did we dressed you mind we
dress when we were engineers we had real
jobs khakis with polo shirt dress
dressed like 55 year old mmm gosh yes I
dress like an 18 year old like people
have commented on that I mean you were
talking about maybe switching up your
wardrobe this summer after your
experience somebody system you're like I
remember you talking I was like I had
some chambray pants or something like
yeah and you're like I had some chambray
pants on this shoot and I'm thinking
about changing everything up yeah yeah
but for him that would be moving from
being a youngster to being like a hobo
yeah I wouldn't get older though he
wouldn't get older he would just get
more comfortable that's a stepping stone
it's like why are you just like a guru
but not old it only works with the man
bun and I don't
so then you just it doesn't really
complete the look but but risk I mean
but a job but a normal job that you
start to assimilate and I mean to do
certain jobs like to be an engineer in
the walk to when I had to walk out on
the floor of the factory at IBM and tell
him the conveyor belt goes here
or you're fired sir because robot is
replacing you like when I would do
things like that and I would my shirt
better be tucked in if you want people
to move that conveyor belt but it can be
all about dress right we can't I don't
super to see my handle and my hairstyle
well ok hairstyles part of it but it but
it's more of a mentality because I I'm
not saying I'm not saying I'm not saying
anything about external stuff cuz I feel
like this is more like internal age
perception I think is that is ultimately
what we're saying I mean we have the
luxury in the in the town that we live
in
yeah the industry that we're in
specifically what our jobs are in the
industry we can kind of just never grow
up externally there will be this time
sooner for us than for you guys and
which is sort of like why is that 50
year old guy dressed like a child and so
there is he's still a youtuber you had
if that's been find a way to make a tree
winners and it will maybe be suddenly
very awkward you know but there were
people like back in Harnett County
growing up like I think coach Brandel my
soccer coach he he never he grew up but
he never grew old like Peter Pan he
would wear like a soccer jersey and
soccer pants and no underwear yeah and
if the light has nothing to do with it
if a light hit is the light hit is
soccer pants just right you could tell
um Bruce he had no underwear on it's
like that's not something a responsible
adult does when you're parading up and
down like a nobody
sadly ever goes command I mean that's
going commando like I mean you you right
when you're born you are but then you've
tuned after wear a diaper and the you
transition to underwear it's like I
I think that actually signifies really
old but he was young at heart Dobbs kids
he's young at heart and okay in science
packs this up this is a good way to live
this is a good way to think about
yourself two researchers at University
College in London looked at the
responses of about sixty five hundred
men and women who answered the question
how old do you feel you are the
respondents were aged 52 and older with
an average age of 65 their answers about
70% felt three or more years younger
than their actual age 25% felt close to
their actual age and 5% felt more than
one year older than their actual age
then eight years after the study
participants answered the age question
oh eight years after the study that
where they answered the question
researchers went back and determined who
was still alive 75 percent of those who
felt older than their age were still
alive 82 percent of those who felt their
actual age were still alive and 86
percent of those who felt younger than
their actual age were still alive so a
10 11 percent increase in longevity but
you know people still being alive after
eight years just because of the
perception of their age then it goes
into talk about like well what is that
if you think that you're younger you
tend to think I've got more of my life
ahead of me you make better choices
about your diet or whatever but I'm sure
there's like Lexus connections that
they'll continue to discover but there's
an argument to be made that when you
kind of grow up and you start seeing
yourself as who you as your actual age
you actually increase your your risk of
dying early or on time and you may be
able to cheat death a little bit if you
think that you're younger than you are
well let's each get in our minds you
know how old we actually feel like we
are and don't say it out loud because I
don't want I don't want I don't want
your answer to sway me because you know
if you say an answer I'll just copy it
so I got how old do we feel
okay got it mm-hmm I got an answer okay
I got mine you can't change your answer
yeah well I'll go for list will they
start from youngest to oldest okay yeah
so Mike now how old are you again I'm 24
25
I feel 19 I like I don't feel any
different than the year I graduated high
school I know I know I am and I've done
something I've done things to show that
I hasn't hindered me I hope but I don't
feel like I think anything really a team
like any differently I know I do but I
don't feel your brain of all of us
you're the only one whose brain is
actually still develop going no your
frontal cortex is still developing and
will until an average age of 26 don't
become as like cognitively capable as
you will be into you're 26 and then you
peak and then it basically starts going
down now which is why we haven't
remember that yeah I just feel like
Mike's might not be I don't wanna like I
don't mean undercut where you're saying
he's been vaping yeah you okay although
I feel well I'm old now well I just I
don't know I feel you're 28 right 28 I
feel 23 okay for years yes because when
you tell me it's been five years since
I've been in college I just think
there's no way like I feel exactly the
same as I did when I was a senior in
college and feel I don't know hmm I just
feel like nothing has changed since that
time but I hope to god some things have
cuz I 2300 expose a mask but still I
feel like mentally I'm pretty much the
same hmm I don't know but that's a big
five years seems like a long time now
that I say it out loud yeah but you
haven't changed and been through a lot
and the in those years I mean it doesn't
necessarily mean you don't
you can't still feel like that right the
same person I mean you're gonna be I
don't know you're gonna be surprised but
I'm going last though so I think you're
gonna be surprised at my number oh I
believe in my heart of hearts that I'm
26 years old yeah 26 26 is it for me
that's yeah yeah I mean I'm younger than
the real you yeah yeah in my mind but
not younger than the you and your mind
right so you're still younger than me on
both accounts an apple this is actually
kind of shocking because I'm gonna give
you my number and then I'm gonna give
you the theory for why you feel how old
you are and I feel how old I am and it's
the same reason so I am 39 will be 40 in
October
I feel 27 that's right so
proportionately correct and and no not
no yes you're you're a year older than
me no because we're both 39 right now
so in this majority but you're about to
be you're practically 40 who we kidding
yeah but that's not that's not the
reason it's not it's not relative it is
the age that we were when we had our
first child yeah you were 26 when Lily
was born and I was 27 when Locke was
born and that was a milestone that was
the last and I didn't listen I didn't
come up with that good I came up with
that irrespective I was like how old do
I feel I was like 27 I feel like my life
while my life has changed drastically
and being the father of two kids or
three kids is different than one kid and
being the father of a teenager is
different than my father of a newborn
but being a father but being a father is
like the last great milestone that we've
experienced and it's also you know after
that magic 26 year old age where you're
fully cognitively developed and it's
like you'll get there man I got I got to
that point and it's like okay I'm
married I got kids I'm a homeowner I got
a job like that was also you know we
hadn't started mythical on her team at
that point but like we had all the
trappings right the things that kind of
define you in your life
and at that point is kind of feel like I
haven't really gotten any older since
then I also feel like I'm kind of
cheating life that I have so many kids
that are as old as they are because out
here in LA you start to feel like people
who have kids my age are a lot older so
it's easier to believe you're yeah out
here
but hold on wouldn't that make me feel
older no makes you feel younger when I
was trying friends yeah parents yeah
they're older than and they're all 10
years older you know because if you got
a 13 year old out here yeah when people
are like got a 13 year old it's like
what you guys when did you have them 13
years ago but but the theory applies to
you guys about the college thing your
last major milestone I've had in my life
yeah honestly well leaving I mean I may
be graduating from college yes the mess
I'm in right three but you don't see
yeah
so that yeah you cross that threshold
yeah and then I mean I sent it like the
next kind of chunk is like post college
and then I started working here which is
like actually been a while 23 yeah but
Mike you feel like okay so in your mind
I know you're getting at college reason
for that college yeah no I probably know
yours too the reason why cuz when I
graduated high school I immediately
within like a month moved to Nashville
okay and then a year after that I moved
to Chicago you can be a country music
singer we didn't know about that I was
gonna be a audio engineer which is what
I originally wanted to do that's a whole
nother story natural for a year then I
moved to Chicago a year after that for
three years and then I moved to LA right
after that so I feel like I've just been
going since I graduated high school
nothing has been like yeah your college
experience is very first ability oh your
I tell you've been like
iterate itinerant how do you say that I
couldn't tell you I did around yeah he
did the idea to ride across America so
immature of me okay so it's well we've
really got that's scary
yeah I can do like divide my life in the
end of college and then post go that's
how I feel right now like I'm developing
as a person
kind of like through college trying to
figure things out and then after that
you're like real world but when does it
change like what a night what is the
next mile we're talking about identity
in terms of like when you when you meet
someone at a party and the first thing
you ask someone is what's your name but
besides the name it's like what do you
do or you know
do you have a partner do you have kids
that type of stuff you know so it's like
these very simplistic over simplify ways
to think about the associate well Who am
I am I am i a dad and what's your dad
there's no going back from that no
recovering from that one and then it's
associated with a certain this is what I
did you know I think a lot about in
terms of being a dad I think about being
young not just for myself now but for my
kids like I like to I mean it's a great
way to connect and bond with the kids to
be like I mean I'm at the dinner table
and Lincoln still got that what's it
called cast it's called a cast he's got
a cast on his arm and people are signing
it now and I'm like oh and these are
people he's meeting at school now and
I'm like who's Gina and I was like don't
write a don't write a VA in front of
that and like that told that's my joke
at dinner at the dinner table
Virginia Gina Gina from Virginia that's
not a joke a dad should make well good
dad unless you're really good I can get
on your love
oh man yeah what this is funny cuz so
Locke was you know getting ready to go
to school first day of like real school
you know and he was we were talking
about what he was gonna wear and he had
like sweatpants oh come on now first day
of school yeah yeah but and then I'm
like you gonna wear sweatpants like they
were like like these but they're not
like they were like cool sweatpants you
know like and they like say like drop
crotch
he's got crotch no I don't know they
were they weren't even drop crotch but
they were like he kind of dresses like
any moment a basketball game could break
out you got to be ready yeah he's really
into basketball but he also was like dad
like it's the jock 70% of the kids will
be wearing sweatpants it's not cuz it
cuz cuz I was like why don't you just
wear like skinny jeans and a button-up
oh yeah very cool and he was like cuz
I'm not of your generation wait how old
I'm like I was thinking yeah good good
call right I'm not saying that there
aren't kids at his school who wear
skinny jeans in a button-up I'm but he's
basically it was the first time where I
was like am I like how'd it is that like
is that like an older guy thing yeah
like kids like not Millennials but
whatever the teenagers are now whatever
that generation is like they thinking
differently about about that and they've
gotten like more casual and their
clothing at least in California and I
was like oh because I I kind of like to
take pride in the fact that like I know
the you know whatever music they want to
listen to it's like we can enjoy it
together it's not like I want you to
listen to Elvis son like you know I like
I can't I connected with my parents
music but it was very much like it was
okay I'm gonna listen to Elvis I'm gonna
listen to Chuck Berry I'm gonna listen
to the Four Seasons because they
listened to those records and they had
them but I was connecting with kind of a
throwback but they weren't listening to
in the 80s I was listening to Michael
Jackson you
in Weird Al I was just into Michael
Jackson sing a song and then weird I'll
sing it again and but they didn't know
or care about any of that
yeah and I'm doing the same thing like
I'm talking like I'm very into music so
I'm like I'm trying to teach Lincoln how
to appreciate Kendrick Lamar and I'm
like listen there's some and help him
process past like foul language and say
okay
there's what's he really talking about
what's he really talking about here so
he started to break this down and then
one morning I was so I was trying to
connect with him when I was playing
Outkast so this was like in 1996 or
maybe 95 song and I Lincoln walks in I'm
like Lincoln there would be no Kendrick
Lamar if it wasn't for outcast so you
sit down and listen to this and I
realized as hip as I thought I was like
this is now the new Harriet thing to say
like me talking about there's this group
called out and there wouldn't be
Kendrick Lamar without Outkast I got
like the one that's even more
embarrassing than that because we were
we were driving along and I was like I
want you kids to listen to what I
thought was like the best music when I
was your age and I played young MC do
you guys know the movie so and I was
like we're gonna listen to the whole
album the whole it's and we could be on
a road it's so yeah we were it's so bad
Outkast in contrast holds up oh oh
but young MC does not hold it up at all
like it's it's so stupid like very
segmented like oh yeah exactly it's not
you know it's not quite like parents
just don't understand it's what I mean
it's kind of the same era but anyway
like and that was the point I was like
this is like I'm rap this is like
getting my kids to listen to something
and then I kind of admitted in the
middle of it's like this isn't this
isn't good as it this is this is this is
kind of embarrassing okay yeah that's
worse
I mean outcast is a legitimate
forefather to Kendrick Lamar and my kids
young is a help it's a valuable part of
their education but I just realized how
long it's been since that I mean we're
talking 20 years
I mean I dove crazy at a moment like
that when I was in New York like just
very very like on that trip because I
was leaving I just had like left the
hotel or something and I remember seeing
like a pack of New York teenagers and I
was like pack oh dang these kids are so
much cooler than what you know I think
I'm a pretty hip you know I know what's
going on with the kids these days I've
seen like these these kids were so much
cooler than I could ever be as I grow up
in New York like they're all dressed way
cooler than mean they have they had like
boom boxes like people did in the 80s
and 90s and stuff like that but they
were like cool new Bluetooth boom boxes
walking these kids are so cool man
so you felt I'm also old and like a
little scared like they could beat me up
at any time they wanted to it was kind
of intense Oh weird there was a physical
yeah Mike have you ever felt old yes
do you ever not feel 19 ever no oh I
don't know have I felt old are you still
nursing I could call entertainment
choices I think we're the same age IRA
do we feel old ever no not yet yeah I
feel when it happens just ignore it like
we do if you want to live forever and I
think the point is is it's also it's
it's okay right it's like it's it's
there's nothing again we're making the
distinction between somebody who never
grows up and never takes responsibility
for their life and somebody who does
take responsibility for their life but
then doesn't completely grow up and is
willing to do childish things it's like
I kind of feel like there's something
inside you that dies a little bit
impossibly yourself later dies when you
just say all right I'm putting all that
aside you
I'm not ever gonna be silly I'm not ever
gonna imagine or do the things the
unreserved things that I would have done
as a child and again some people are
lucky and they get to do it for their
job we get to just act like fools when
and if if you were to take and do the
stuff that we do on our shows at your
house or at your school you'd be
expelled box boxing is nada but you know
one of the cool things that I have seen
a lot of times is I'll see like a fan
video of like a father and a son doing
like their own Willet or doing like
something that we did on the show yeah
we had a kid who spent 24 hours in a box
after we did after we did our photobooth
thing and he's like mom sent us like
updates they're like here he goes he's
about to start
24 hours in this cardboard box where was
the box like just in his living room he
wasn't really roughing it like we were
but still it was like dope it was cool
it is like I don't know even his mom
just yeah being a part of that yeah it's
like her participating in in that
tomfoolery you know did he do it yeah
yeah we got it we got a video of him
coming out at it like our 24 who's stuff
yeah it was fun of course you guys
didn't actually do it every time I
showed up you were in there yeah exactly
that's why I mean that's why you were
laughing so hard that morning it's
because you couldn't believe that we're
so right yeah yeah hey you know it's
just coming up with something that's
ridiculous but then saying who knows
what we're gonna learn or how we're
gonna grow as people or like our brains
I mean the science of it you start to
make all these you go out on so many
limbs your brain grows man it connects
oh you think the brain is growing and
connecting grows and connects man it
keeps you it keeps you alive when you
when you say you know what I'm gonna I'm
gonna jump in headfirst baby yeah what a
for eclis speaking but in Amenas
and to check the depth this is anecdotal
you you you you know they're they're
just people who are like I'm old oh I
can't do that anymore
well that was something I was gonna ask
actually it's like people one of the few
negative notes that we ever get is like
oh this is so immature or something I
didn't know like how you guys kind of
react to that or what you think about
that like when people come at you
there's like not much bad you can say
about the shows I think in my opinion
but like the only negative notes that
we've gotten is really oh that's so dumb
or let's so immature but it's I don't
know I that's kind of it's a little
upsetting that people are so quick to
discredit for that reason it's like yeah
it's it's dumb but it took forever to
come up with this you didn't come up
with this I know it was a cool thing to
do I just think that if somebody says
that about one of your videos they're
just not getting the joke
Yeah right it's like do you really think
that the main motivation here is to
really figure out how to get inside of a
bear that's almost part of the fun that
we're legitimately any question but it's
really for that moment that we can be
two bears fighting each other yeah
and there's just a it's just like we
talked about in the book it's when we
were inside that cereal bowl and I
actually saw on Facebook recently there
they reposted it
somebody had curated to five top moments
of link freaking out or whatever and one
of them is in a cereal bowl and that was
there was like this pure I mean I was
there too it was kind of a bigger moment
for you than it was me but we were there
as well for both but there's this
flashback yeah pure like unadulterated
joy and euphoria of just being able to
do something like that without regard to
anybody's perception of it yeah and
people are gonna be like this is dumb I
don't get it this is immature or this is
a waste of cereal donated gave it to
horses but it's that moment I mean it's
it's that moment I remember the first
time I successfully rode a bike like I
was my aunt TC was gonna teach me to
ride
I can she did that thing where she was
like holding onto the back and running
with me and then and we were going
around the house
and then one time I came around the
house and when I came around the house I
saw and I knew she couldn't be behind me
anymore and I was like it was it felt
like I was flying I felt like I was
flying and then I fell before I felt
that was ever I mean that moment was
something that I felt when I when I came
up out of that cereal and I know you
guys feel it I mean that's the magic
that she captured it's not just okay
they actually did it but they
experienced it you know you if you
experience life man you grab it by the
balls
you embrace in maturity and it's um is
something to be celebrated not something
to be apologized for
[Music]